[Alkış]
Selamlar herkese
Evet benim konum başarının
psikolojisiyle alakalı Neden böyle bir
konu anlatacağım birçok şeyle
uğraşıyorum hayatımda ve şunu fark ettim
ki aslında
başarmanın bir psikolojisi var yani
bizim kabiliyetimiz gücümüzden daha çok
bir psikolojisi var hatta bunu gençlerin
de çoğunlukta olduğu bir ortamda
anlatmaktan daha çok memnunum peki Yani
neler yapıyorum bunu tetiksin kendi
sayfasından aldım bunlar benim
etiketlerim değil hayatta ilgilendiğim
konular
bir Tıp doktoruyum Öncelikle bir arama
kurtarma gönüllüsüyüm akut arama
kurtarma Derneği'nde yıllardır Dünyayı
Geziyorum özellikle sırt çantasıyla
gezmeye bayılırım
ralli pilotuyum Yine aşağı yukarı 25
yıldır otomobil sporlarıyla ilgiliyim
motosiklet kullanıyorum Doğa aşığıyım
iyi bir gözlemci olduğumu düşünüyorum
davul çalıyorum yeni gitara başladım Bu
arada
ve sonuçta Aslında en önem Ben
öğrenciyim öğreneceğim hayatta ve zaten
buradan öğrendiğim birkaç konuyu
sizlerle paylaşacağım yaptığım bazı
faaliyetlerden bazı kareler var burada
Peki bunları öğrenirken nasıl bir süreç
geçirdim hayatımda benim okul hayatım
çok not olarak iyi geçmedi yani annem
babam birazcık uğraşmak zorunda kalmıştı
yetecek kadar not aldım hep
Sonuçta yine tıbbi kazanabildim daha 6
sene önce medikal estetik alanında Bir
konuya tekrar başladım geçenlerde bir
kongreye konuşmacı olarak çağırdılar Bir
tık kongresine
otomobil sporları çok tutkumdu hep
arabalar otomobil sporlarına başladım
dedim ki ya ben iyiyimdir Muhtemelen
hani çok da seviyorum falan iki sene
sonuncu oldum bayağı bildiğiniz listeye
sondan bakıyorduk biz kaçıncı olmuşuz
diye son bir sonraki falan ama devam
ettik Daha sonrasında birçok
birincilikler 4 kere Türkiye
şampiyonluğu oldu otomobil sporlarında
yine yani her konuyla alakalı konuşacak
olursak hepsinin arkasında bir başlangıç
dönemi bir uğraşma dönemi var dağcılıkta
Bunlardan bir tanesi Şimdi dağcılıkla
alakalı
Yani aranız var mı dağcılık yapan bu
arada
seven Neden peki
şimdi başarıyla alakalı nasıl anlatırım
acaba Bu psikolojiyi diye çok düşündüm
dedim ki dağcılığı Metafor olarak
kullanabilirim ve bununla ilgili de bir
Video çektim ama bir başarı daha önceden
yapılmamış olsa dahi
başarılması mümkün Aslında her şeyin
başarılması mümkün bir kere bundan yola
çıkmak lazım diye düşünüyorum
bizim başarmak istediğiniz konu neler
Çünkü bu aslında konuşmayı tek başıma
yapıyor olmayacağım
ekranın yarısında Siz olacaksınız
yarısında ben olacağım Onun için sizden
ricam çok Birkaç saniye içinde ben ya şu
konuyu başarmak istiyorum diye
içinizden seçebilir misiniz yani şu
anlık bize söylemenize gerek yok ama
ileride Umarım ki ya ben o zaman
düşündüğüm şeyi başardım derseniz daha
ileride karşılaştığımızda
Eğer düşündüysek şöyle başlayalım şimdi
dediğim gibi bir dağa çıkmaya karar
verdim bunları nasıl anlatır mı çözmek
için tek başıma değildim bir ekibim var
beni arama kurtarma derneğinden 5
Kişiydik dağcılıkta bir dağa çıkmadan
önce gidersiniz orada kalırsınız geceden
Yani bir gün önce gidersiniz çünkü
sabaha karşı dağa çıkmaya başlanır neden
Çığ riski daha düşük olur Çünkü hava
ısındıkça Çığ riske artar Biz bozdağ'a
gittik Bozdağ gerçekten İzmir Bozdağ
bilenleriniz var mı
biraz Bravo birkaç kişi biliyor riskli
bir dağdır
birkaç kez arama kurtarma operasyonuna
gittik
ekibimle daha öncelerden ve maalesef
bazıları kötü sonuçlandı yine Çığ ile
alakalı sıkıntılardan dolayı
bizde Yani bu da bir faaliyet
gerçekleştirdik arkadaşlarımla şimdi bu
tarafta ben varım
şu tarafta siz varsınız sizin Seçtiğiniz
hedefinizle alakalı sol taraf
dağcılıkta Tabii ki riskler var ya bir
cesareti istiyordum ya cesaret ne demek
yani belli riskleri alabilmeye cesaret
deniyor Peki Cüret etmek ne demek bence
çok daha önemli bir anlamı var cüret
etmenin hayatta başarılmamış bir şeylere
de başarmaya insana sevk edebiliyor
cüret edebiliyorsanız Eğer
sizin hedefinizde de muhtemelen belli
riskler olabilir Bunları düşünmenizi
istiyorum Bu riskleri alacak
cesaretimizi ilk önce toplamamız çok çok
önemli dağcılıkta hedefle Vizyon nedir
zirvedir Eğer bir Zirve tırmanışı
yapıyorsanız sizin hedefiniz orasıdır
vizyonunuz da orasıdır ama
zirveyi göremezsiniz dağıtırmanırken
daha yaklaşırsanız yaklaştıkça Zirve
iyice görünmez olur ama orada olduğunu
bilirsiniz yine de doğru mu bildiğiniz
bir şeydir Aslında yine de
Biz de şu an uzak görünüyor olabilir ama
ona ulaşmak Yani onun orada olduğunu
bilmek çok çok önemli Hedefi olmayanlar
ne olur Daha da kaybolur bir hedefi
vardır bir bağa giden birisinin hayatta
aynı şekilde sonra ne geliyor psikolojik
bir hazırlık dönemi geliyor bu dönemi
çok iyi geçirmek gerektiğini düşünüyorum
burada Peki ne yapacağız psikolojik
hazırlık döneminde ilk önce diyeceğiz ki
ya ben Neden bunu yapıyorum Neden bunu
istiyorum ne gibi riskler var ne gibi
risklerle karşılaşabilirim burada neler
yapacağım kafamda bir daha her şeye bir
cekettim psikolojik olarak önce
kendimizi hazırladık daha o daha çıkma
eylemine başlamadan önce sizin şu sol
tarafta belirlediğiniz konuyla alakalı
da size tavsiyem önce psikolojik olarak
hazırlayın kendinizi
sonra fiziksel bir hazırlık dönemi
geliyor Doğru mu bu bizim için yani
bedenimizle yaptığımız bir spor olduğu
için bir egzersiz olabilir Siz Belki
bunu bambaşka bir şekilde hazırlanarak
geçireceksiniz Belki bir eğitim
alacaksınız Belki başka bir şey
yapacaksınız bu arada kısa kısa birkaç
tane video çektim o dağa çıkarken onun
hikayesiyle ilgili de çok önemli bir
nokta var ki Bence başarının sırrı orada
oraya geldiğimizde söyleyeceğim
tabii ama bu süreçlerin hepsi önemli mi
Evet hepsi önemli ama bir tanesi var ki
başarılı insanla başarısız insana
ayırıyor
odaklanmak odaklanmak çok çok yine
önemli bir konu doğru mu yani biz daha
faaliyeti yaparken ya yarın Ne Giysem
acaba işte ne yemek pişirsek Evde falan
hani böyle şeyler düşünmüyoruz tahmin
edersiniz ki bir işte hele hele ciddi
büyük bir işi başarmaya çalışan insan
başka hiçbir şey düşünmez izole eder Her
şeyi hayatımda defalarca yaşadım o
yüzden Başarının Psikolojisi olduğunu
bildiğimden bahsediyorum Çok kısa bir
hikaye anlatayım bununla alakalı yine
uludağ'dayız bir arama kurtarma Opera
eğitimindeyiz özür dilerim Akıt olarak
iki tane Dağcı tırmanmaya başladı
Bizlere her şey sev diye medyaya işte
Bütün malzeme var zaten eğitim
yaptığımız için kalabalığız da biz bir
gözümüzün ucuyla takip ediyoruz Onlar
tırmanıyorlar bir yandan
bir şey oldu bir tanesi düşmeye başladı
Kaydı Kaydı Kaydı artık diyoruz yani ne
zaman duracak Kayalık bir bölüm vardı
oraya geldi kramponu takıldı oradan
uçtuk geriye Allah'tan Her taraf kar
düştü Biz zaten o arada koşmaya
başlamıştık 5 dakikada falan yanına
ulaştık
yani Ayağında kırık vardı iyi Bu arada
bir sıkıntı olmadı büyük bir sıkıntı
dedim ki ne yaptın dedim ya
tırmanıyordunuz yani gayet iyi
gidiyordunuz Ne oldu dedim ya arkadaşım
arabanın anahtarını aldık mı diye sordu
dedi Ben de cebime bakmaya çalıştım dedi
arkadaşlar Odak dağıtmak büyük riskler
taşıyabilir her şeyde sadece dağcılıkta
değil o şanslıydı Bu arada Peki dua
şartları bizim kontrolümüzün dışında
olan şeyler var yani bizle alakası yok
ama oluyor değil mi Yani bizim için doğa
şartları sizin tarafta da oluyor yani
sizin o hedefinize gittiğiniz yerde de
sizin kontrolünüzün dışında olan olaylar
vardı Doğru mu
o olayları okuyabiliyor olmanız önemli
kontrol etmekten bahsetmiyorum kontrol
edemezsiniz ama okuyabilip ona göre
belki önlemler alıp Belki biraz
erteleyip yapacağınız şeyi şartların
uygun olduğu bir zamana seçebilirsiniz
değil mi Bununla ilgili çok kısa bir
video var o faaliyetten beraber
izleyelim
arkadaşlar eldivenler gördüğünüz gibi
biraz sesi açabilir miyiz
birazcık soğuk
yani gördüğünüz gibi eldivenler buz
tuttu soğuktan
sonradan elimizde açılıyor bu bir gün
öncesi Bu arada biz daha yeni başlamışız
gitmişiz bir gün önceden 5 kişi orada
kamp kurmuşuz Konfor alanından çıkmışız
Yani doğru mu Konfor alanı nedir Yani bu
dağcılıkta hani evdeki sıcacık Evde
otururken ne işim var Eksi 20'lerde ki
konu Bizim diğer yapmak istediğimiz
şeylerde şu da olabilir ya bana Herkesin
güvendiği beni onayladığı ortam ne güzel
Konfor alan değil mi riske girmek
istemiyorum yani başka bir iş yapayım da
bunu yapamadı derlerse gibi arkadaşlar
Konfor alanından çıkmadan Hayatta hiçbir
başarı elde edilmiyor şimdi bakın
çadırın içindeki durumumuz nasıl burada
kalıyoruz gece
Yani kamera bile buz tutmuş
Ya böyle bir ortamda gece
konaklıyorsunuz yanımızda yetecek kadar
yiyecekler yetecek kadar beslenecek
şeyler ve su var arkadaşlar dağcılıkta
Rota çok önemli bir konu değil mi
önceden çalışırız rotaya bazen bir dağın
zirvesinin birkaç Rotası olabilir
bunlara da hakim olmaya çalışırız Siz de
yapacağınız şeyde kafanızda bir Rotayı
belirleyip planlayın bunu Yani ne
yapacağım bundan sonra ne olacak bundan
sonra ne olacak gibi Kafamızda plan
olsun hepsini bir anda yapmak zorunda
değiliz Bu arada ve daha acılıkta teknik
malzeme ve eğitim hayatidir çünkü normal
de bir insanın hiçbir şeyi olmadan o
dağa koyarsanız yaşayamaz yani buna
güveniriz Biz hem de malzemeyi iyi
kullanmaya da
sizin o biraz önce aklınızdan geçen ya
benim şöyle bir hedefim var demiştiniz
ya belki malzeme gerekiyordur Belki de
çok iyi bir eğitim belki işte egzersiz
Belki başka bir şey bilmiyorum ama iyi
hazırlanmanız lazım iyi öğrenmeniz Hele
bir şeye cüret ediyorsanız
herkesten daha iyi öğrenmeniz lazım
yine bu benim de çok çok sevdiğim bir
laf bir Afrika atasözü diyor ki hızlı
gitmek istiyorsan yalnız uzağa gitmek
istiyorsan beraber git diyor
ekibinize güvenmeniz lazım dağcılıkta
ekip olmazsa olmaz çok kısa bir video
var yine size bunu izlettireceğim
şu gördüğünüz Rota biraz buzlu yan
tarafı da Yamaç arcakayalardan dolayı
birazcık çay may riski var
Ondan dolayı
ipe giriyoruz arkadaşlar
3 metre demir
olacak ki birisi kayarsa eğer
kusura bakmayın çekim için ses biraz
Bazen karışabiliyor arkadaşlar yine
buraya geleyim burada ilk birliğine
giriyoruz buna daha çok da ip kardeşliği
deniyor neden kardeşlik ya Çünkü hayatın
birbirine bağlı ve birisi kaysa bile
öbürleri durdurabiliyor hayatta da böyle
bir şey var hayatta
ekibin gücünü yatsımamak lazım Bir şeyi
yaparken ne olursa olsun ekipçe yapıyor
olmanın gücünü mutlaka hissetmek
Birbirimize yardım etmek lazım ki daha
ilerilere gidebilelim peki başka ne var
daha da yorulmak kadar normal bir şey
yok ben bu faaliyete çıktığımda o kadar
kondisyonsuzdum ki birazdan anlatacağım
en önemli yeri dediğim yeri zaten
ama yorulabilir insanı mı duramaz
durduğunuz anda daha da donarsınız çünkü
Büyük Risk içerir Peki sizin Biraz önce
belirlediğiniz hedefinizde ne olur En
başa döndürür sizi Belki bıraktırır
hatta eğer durursanız o yüzden yavaş
yavaş da olsa bir şeyler yapıyor olmaya
oyunun içinde kalmaya devam ediyor
olmamız lazım
ve arkadaşlar 5 Kişiydik demiştim bir
arkadaşımız daha yolun dörtte biriydi
dedi ki ben bittim ya dedik Daha dur
hani yeni başladı ısınırsın ver dedik
Çantanı biz alalım hani malzemeleri biz
yardım edelim sana biraz ikna oldu biraz
daha gittik
sonra ilk molada ben dedi gerçekten
bittim bakın malzemesi her şeyi çok
iyiydi
dinlenmişti her şeyi çok iyiydi ama
bence psikolojisi
devam edecek kadar hazır değildi
Peki dedik yani artık ısrar edecek bir
durumda kalmadı dedik çadırlar görünüyor
şurası güvenli yol Yani buradan git
Akşama Geleceğiz oraya Sen bekle bizi
orada dedik ve döndü
yine bir kısa bilgi var
saat 2 şu anda öğleden sonra
Yarım saat bir saate
zirveye varmış olacağız
hiçbir faaliyet tabii kolay değil aslına
bakarsanız hiçbir yeriniz zirvesine
çıkmak kolay değil
kolay olsaydı zaten zevki de vermiyor
olurdu gerçekten
tek bir şey var bizim de kışın ki aslına
bakarsanız ilk daha faaliyetimiz
ve çok formunda olmasın
yola devam ediyoruz Burada en önemli şey
yoldan geri dönmek arkadaşlar
dönmediğine
hızlı yavaş hareket etmez sabah mutlaka
zirveye böyle yapıyorsunuz
Evet buralarda video çekiyorum ama yani
ne kadar zorlandığımı tarif edemem size
çok uzakta ulaşılmaz görünebiliyor bazen
bir yerler değil mi hayatta Aslında
bunların hepsi Yani sürekli bir ufak
adımla ulaşılıyor yani Zirve everest'in
zirvesine çıkan kişi de o adımlara
atarak Hatta bir yerden sonra çok daha
yavaş adım atarak Gitmeye devam ediyor
ama çıkıyor zirveye Sonuçta sizin
yapacağınız işte de şu anda bir anda bir
şeyi başarmak bir anda sonuca gelmek
değil konu sadece önce yakın hedefleri
tutturuyor olmamız gerekiyor sonradan
hayalimizdeki hedefe gitmiş oluruz zaten
tamam zor olabilir Bir zirveye gitmek
ama sizin için değerse zorluklardan daha
fazla bir nedeniniz varsa o zaman o
zorluklara her türlü katlanıyorsunuz
Onun için Umarım güçlü nedenleriniz olan
bir şey yapıyorsunuzdur geldim en önemli
yerine sonlarına da geldim zaten
Arkadaşlar bir dakikalık bir düşünce
geçti aklımdan
ve bunun sonucunu yaşadım hayatımda
Hayat hep böyle hayatta her şey böyle
Aslında ve bunun için Başarının
Psikolojisi var başarının gücü falan
değil başarılı 16 yolu değil psikolojisi
var başarının aslında Sadece
o kadar yoruldum ki yani şimdi Normalde
yürüme işlemi nasıl oluyor yani bunu
düşünerek yapmıyoruz değil mi Bir adım
öbürüne Normalde takip eder Ben bunu
planlayarak Yani bu bacağa kaldıracağım
bunun önüne koyacağım deyip içi derin
nefes alıp sonra bir tane daha adım atıp
yanıyor bacaklarım Çünkü artık
yorgunluktan
aklımdan bir dakika da şunlar geçti
Dedim ki hepsi samimi arkadaşım Biraz
önce de biri dönmüş zaten hani dönen de
var Ben döndüm desem kimse bana Bir şey
demeyecek dedim ben söyleyeyim bunlara
Ben de yapamayacağım yani Ben dönüyorum
Buradan yarısını da geçmiştik yolun
aslında
bunu düşünürken
Kendime şunu sordum Dedim ki ya Ben
hayatımda böyle bir anım olsun istiyor
muyum
Biz hep beraber bozdağ'a gittik gece
kaldık yola çıktık ve ben yarısından
geri döndüm böyle bir anım dedim ben
olsun istemiyorum hayatımda ve bir
dakikanın sonunda
beynimden çıkan karar şu oldu dedim gece
12'de olsa ben dedim o zirveye gidiyorum
ve devam ettim Çok zor oldu bu arada siz
de belki bu tür zorluklar yaşayacaksınız
burada ama beyninizden o düşüncenizin
sonucunda çıkan davranış sizin başarısız
başarılı veya başarısız olmanızın nedeni
olacak potansiyelinizin farkında olun
arkadaşlar
fiziksel olarak da psikolojik olarak da
insan farkında bile değil neler
yapabileceğini İnanın bana o kadar büyük
bir Aslında potansiyelimiz var ki Şimdi
desem ki şuradan 100 kilometre Hadi
yürüyelim de deli misin falan dersiniz
Yani insanlar savaş zamanında alıyor
onları sırtına Bir de malzemeyle
yürüyorlar orada insanın kapasitesi çok
daha fazla ama biz psikolojik olarak
kendimizi durduruyoruz
ve başarı aslında Sadece şu
düşünce farkı sadece vazgeçenler devam
edenler
bu kadar Bu hangi şartta olursa olsun
son video ve bitiriyorum arkadaşlar
[Müzik]
işte manzara
Heyecanımı mazur görür iki gündür
uğraşmışız sonunda zirveye ulaşınca
böyle oluyor insan çok teşekkür ediyorum
Çok sağ olun ve
arkadaşlar Umarım siz de kendi
hedeflerinizin zirvelerine ulaşırsınız
ve dünyadaki en önemli kişiye kendinize
inanın diyorum görüşmek üzere
[Alkış]